the following content is provided under
a creative commons license
your support will help mit
opencourseware continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of mit courses
visit mit opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hello and welcome to 601
i'm danny freeman i'm the lecturer
one thing you should know about today is
that there's a single handout you should
have picked it up on your way in that's
available at either the two doors
what i want to do today
in this first lecture
is mostly focus on content
but before i do that since 601 is a
little bit of an unusual course i want
to give you a little bit of an overview
and tell you a little bit about the
administration of the course
601
is
mostly
about modes of reasoning
what we would like you to get out of
this course is ways to think about
engineering
we want to talk about how do you design
how do you build how do you construct
how do you debug
complicated
systems that's what engineers do
and we're very good at it
and that we want to make you very good
at it
we're very good at it and you know that
from your common everyday experience
laptops are incredible
as we go through the course you're going
to see
that laptops incorporate things from the
tiniest tiniest level
things so small that you can't see them
they're microscopic the individual
transistors are not things that you can
see
we develop special tools for you even to
be able to visualize them
and yet we conglomerate billions of them
into a system that works relatively
reliable now i realize i'm going out on
the limb because you when you say things
like that then things always fail but
i'll go out on a limb and say for the
most part
the systems that we construct are very
reliable
we'd like you to know how you think
about making such a complicated system
and making it reliable
we want to tell you about how you would
model things
how do you gain insight how do you get
predictability how do you figure out how
something will work before you've built
it
if you're limited to try out how things
work by actually constructing it
you spend a lot of time constructing
things that never make it
we want to avoid that
by where we can
making a model analyzing the model
making a prediction from the model and
using that prediction to build a better
system on the first
try we want to tell you about how to
augment the physical behavior of a
system by putting computation in it
that's a very
powerful technique that is increasingly
common
in anything from a microwave to a
refrigerator
we'd like you to know the principles by
which you do that
and we'd like you to be able to build
systems that are robust to failure
that's a newer idea
it's something that people are very good
at
if we try to do something and we make a
mistake we know how to fix it
and often the fix works
we're less good at doing that in
constructing artificial systems in
engineering systems and we'd like to
talk about principles by which we can do
that
so the goal of 601 is then really to
convey a distinct perspective
about how we engineer systems
now having said that
this is not a philosophy course
we are not going to make lists of things
to do if you want it to be robust
we're going to learn to do things by
actually making systems this is an
introductory engineering course and so
you're going to build things
the idea is going to be that in
constructing those things we've rigged
the exercises so that some of those
important themes become transparent
so we the idea is this is introductory
engineering you all make things you all
get things to work and in the process of
doing that learn something about the
bigger view
of how
quality engineering happens
so the so
despite the fact that we're really about
modes of reasoning
that will be grounded in content
we selected the content very broadly
from across eecs ecs is an enormous
endeavor
we can't possibly introduce everything
about eecs in one subject that's
ridiculous
however we wanted to give you a variety
we wanted to give you a sense of the
variety of tasks that you can use that
you can
that you can apply the same techniques
to so we want to introduce modes of
reasoning and then show you explicitly
how you can use those modes of reasoning
in a variety of contexts
so we've chosen four and we've organized
the course around four modules
first module is software engineering
then signals and systems and circuits
and probability and planning
even so
even having chosen just four out of the
vast number of things we could have
chosen there's no way we can tell you
adequately
we can't give you an adequate
introduction to any of those things
either
what we've chosen to do instead
is focus on key concepts
represented by the asterisks
the idea is going to be we choose one or
two things
and really focus on those deeply so you
get a thorough understanding not only of
how that fits within for example the
context of software engineering but also
how that concept ramifies into other
areas notice that i tried to choose the
stars so they hit multiple circles
that's what we're trying to do we're
trying to not only introduce an idea to
you but also show you how it connects
to other ideas
um
so the idea then is to focus on a few
we hope very well chosen applications
that will demonstrate a variety of
powerful techniques
our mantra
the way we intend to go about teaching
this stuff
is practice
theory
practice
there's an enormous educational
literature that says
whether you like it or not
people learn better when they're doing
things
you have a lot of experience with that
you have a lot of experience on the
other side too
i'll try to forget the other side or at
least try to wipe it from your brain
momentarily
to focus on your more fundamental modes
of learning
when you were a kid and you were
learning your first language
you didn't learn all the rules of
grammar first you didn't learn all the
letters of the alphabet first you didn't
learn about conjugating verbs first
you learned a little bit about language
you started to use it you ran into
problems you learned a little more about
language
you learn to con
to go from words like feed me
to higher level concepts like hey what's
for dinner
so the idea is
that you learned it in an iterative
process where you learned some stuff
tried it out learned some more stuff
tried it out and it built up
there's an enormous literature in
education that says that's exactly how
we always learn everything
and so that's the way this course is
focused what we will do is for example
for today we'll learn a little bit about
software engineering
then we'll do two lab sessions where you
actually try to use the things that we
talk about
then we'll come back to lecture and
we'll have some more theory about how
you would uh do programming
and then you go back to the lab and do
some more stuff
and the hope is that by
by this tangible context
you'll have a deeper appreciation of the
ideas that we're trying to convey
so
let me tell you a little bit about the
four modules that we've chosen the
course is going to be organized on four
modules
each module will take about one-fourth
of the course first thing we'll look at
is software engineering
as i said we don't have time to focus on
or even survey the big id all of the big
ideas in software engineering it's far
too big so we're going to focus narrowly
on one or two things
we'd like you to know about abstraction
and modularity because that's such an
important idea
in the construction of big systems
so that's going to be our focus we'll
begin in today's lecture
we'll begin talking about
uh modularity and abstraction at the
small scale
how does it affect the things you type
as instructions to a computer
but by next week we're going to be
talking about a whole bigger scale
by next week we're going to talk about
constructing software modules
at a much higher level in particular
we'll talk about something that we'll
call a state machine
a state machine is a thing
that works in steps
on every step
the state machine gets a new input
then based on that input and its memory
of what's come before
the state machine decides to do
something it generates an output and
then the process repeats
we will see that that kind of an
abstraction state machines
has a there's a way to think about state
machines that is compositional that you
can
think of as a hierarchy just as you can
think of
low-level hierarchies within a language
i'll say a lot more about that today
so the idea will be that once you've
composed a state machine
you'll be able to join two-state
machines and have this behavior look
just like one state machine
that's a way to get a more complicated
behavior
by constructing two simpler behaviors
that's what we want we want to learn
tools that lets us compose complex
behaviors out of simple behaviors and
the tangible model of that will be the
robot
we will see how to write a program that
controls a robot
as
a state machine
that's certainly not the only way you
could control a robot and it's probably
not the way you would first think of it
if you
took one course in programming and
somebody said to you go program the
robot to do something
what we will see is that it's a very
powerful way to think about it for
exactly this reason of modularity
the bigger point that we will make in
thinking about this first module is the
idea of
how do you make systems modular how do
you use abstraction to simplify the
design task and in particular we will
focus on something that we'll call pcap
when you think about a system we will
always think about it in terms of what
are the primitives
how do you combine them
how do you abstract a bigger behavior
from those smaller behaviors
and what are the patterns that are
important to to capture
so the bigger point is this idea of pcap
which we will then revisit in every
subsequent model a module
okay second module is on signals and
systems
that's also an enormous area
so we only have time to do one thing the
thing that we will do is
we will think about discrete time
feedback
how do you make a system that's
cognizant
of what it's done
so that it in the future can do things
with awareness
of how it got there
a good example is robotic
so the idea is going to be okay think
about what you do when you're driving a
car
and think about how you would tell a
robot to do that same thing
here's a naive driving algorithm i don't
recommend it but it's widely used in
boston apparently
i find myself to the right of where i
would like to be so what should i do
turn left
i'm still to the right of where i'd like
to be what should i do
turn left
oh
i'm exactly where i should be
what should i do
go straight ahead
oh that's a bad idea
and what we'll see is that perfectly
innocent looking algorithms can have
horrendous performance
what we'll do
is try to make an abstraction of that
we'll try to make a model
we'll try to capture that in math so
that we don't need to build it to see
the bad behavior
we'll make a model
we'll use the model to predict that that
algorithm
stinks but more importantly we'll use
the model to figure out an algorithm
that will work better
in fact we'll even be able to come up
with bounds
on how well
such a controller could possibly
work so the focus in this module is
going to be how do you make a model to
predict behavior how do you analyze the
model
so that you can design a better system
and then how do you use the model in the
analysis to
to make a
well-behaved system
the third module is on circuits
again circus is huge
we don't have time to talk about all the
circuits we'll do very simple things
we'll focus our attention on how you
would add a sensory capability
to an already complicated system
the idea is going to be to start with
the robot i guess this is brighter start
with our robots
and design a head
for the robot
the robot comes from the factory with
sonar sensors the sonar sensors are
these things there's eight of them they
tell you how far away something that
reflects the ultrasonic wave
is
as they come from the factory the robots
can't sense light
what you'll do is add light sensors
the goal is to make a system
to modify the robot so that the robot
tracks light
so it's a very simple goal
and the way we'll do that
is to augment the robot with a simple
sensor here showed a little more
magnified here
the idea is that this is a lego motor
the lego motor will let will turn this
relative to the attachment
that's the robot head's neck
so you the robot will be able to do this
and the robot will have eyes these are
photo sensors photo resistors actually
so the idea is going to be that there's
information available in those sensors
for figuring out where a light is so
that you could track it
your job will be to build a circuit
that's this thing
that connects via cables these red
cables and yellow cables connects by
cables over to this head we'll give you
the head
your job will be to make the circuit
that converts the
signal from the photoresistor which is
in proportion to light
and figures out how to turn the motor to
get the head
to face the light
and then shift that information down to
the robot to let the robot turn its
wheels to get the body
so it's kind of like
the light comes on braid over here the
robot looks at it oh yeah that's where i
want to be
so that's the idea in the third module
is to incorporate new sensing
capabilities into the
robot
the final module is on probability and
planning
and the idea there
is to learn about how you make
systems
that are robust to uncertainty
and that can
make
can implement complicated plans
that they too are robust to uncertainty
so there's a number of things that we
will do including uh creating maps of
spaces that the robot doesn't understand
telling the figuring that telling the
robot how to localize itself how
how if it woke up suddenly in an
environment it could figure out where it
is
uh how to make a plan
and as an example
i'll show you the kind of system that we
will construct
here the idea is that we have a robot
the robot knows where it is
imagine there's a gps in it there isn't
but imagine there is so the robot knows
where it is and it knows where it wants
to go that's the star
but it has no idea what kind of
obstacles are in the way
so you know if you were a robotic driver
in boston
you know that you started out at home
and you want to end up in mit
but there's these annoying obstacles you
know they're called people
that you should in principle at least
you know
miss
okay so that's that's kind of the idea
so the so
i know where i am i'm the robot i know
where i am i know where i want to be and
i'm going to summarize that information
here
where i am is purple where i want to be
is gold
and i have a plan
that's blue
my plan is very simple i don't know
anything about anything other than i'm
in i'm in waltham and i want to go to
cambridge so you know blast east
so i imagine that the best way to do
there is a straight line
okay so now what i'm going to do is uh
turn on the robot the robot has now made
one step
and i told you before about these
sonar sensors
from the sonar sensors the robot has
learned now that there seems to be
something reflecting
at each of these black dots
it got a reflection from the black dots
from the from the sonar sensors that
means there's probably a wall there or a
person or something that in principle i
should avoid
so
uh and the red dots represent
okay the obstacle is so close i really
can't get there
so i'm excluded from the red spots
because i'm too big
the black the black spots seem to be an
obstacle the red spots seem to be where
i can't fit
i'd still want to go from from where i
am purple to where i want to be gold so
what i do is i compute a new plan
okay then
i start to take a step along that plan
and as i'm stepping
along
okay so now i think that i can't go from
where i started over to here i have to
go around this wall that i didn't know
about initially
so now i just start driving and it looks
fine right i'm getting there
right so now i know i can go straight
down here oh wait a minute there's
another wall okay what do i do now
so as the robot goes around along
it didn't know when it started what
kinds of obstacles it would encounter
but as it's driving it oh
that didn't work start over
so the idea is
that
this robot
is executing a very complicated plan
the plan has in fact many sub plans
and the sub plans all involve
uncertainty it didn't know where the
walls were when it started
and when it's all done it's going to
have figured out where the walls were
and provided those away
presumably find the way to negotiate the
maze and get to the to the destination
so the idea then is that the if you were
to ask if you were asked to write a
conventional kind of program
for solving that it might be kind of
hard because of the number of
contingencies involved
what we will do is break down the
problem and figure out simple and
elegant ways to deal not only with
uncertainty but how do you make complex
plans
so as i said
our primary pedagogy
is going to be practice
theory
practice
and so that ramifies
in how the course is organized
so this is a quick map
of some of the aspects of the course
so
we'll have weekly lectures it's lecture
unintensive in total there's only 13
lectures
we'll meet once a week here for lecture
there's readings
there's voluminous readings there's
readings about every topic that we will
talk talk about and the readings were
specifically designed for this course i
highly recommend that you become
familiar with the readings if you have a
question after lecture it's probably
there it's probably explained
we will do online tutor problems we sent
you an email if you pre-registered for
the course so you may already know about
this the idea is going to be that
there's
ways that you can prepare for the course
by doing computer exercises
and we will also use those same kinds of
exercises in all of the class sessions
we will have two kinds of lab
experiences besides lecture
the other two events that have that you
have to attend are a software lab and a
design lab
that's the practice part
so after you learn a little bit about
the theory by going to lecture by by
doing the reading then you go to the lab
and try some things out
we call the first lab a software lab
it's a short lab it's an hour and a half
you work individually you try things out
you write little programs the the
courseware can check the program to see
if it's okay
and
primarily the exercises in the software
lab are due during the software lab but
on occasion there will be extra things
due a day or two later
the due dates are very clearly written
in the tutor exercises
once a week there's a design lab that's
a three hour session in which you work
with a partner
the reason for the partner
is that the
intent the difference between the design
labs and the software labs is that the
design labs
ask you to solve slightly more
open-ended questions
the kind of question that you might have
no clue what we're asking
open-ended the kind of thing that you
will be asked to do after you graduate
design the system what do you mean
design the system
so the idea is that working with a
partner will give you
a second immediate source of help
and a little more confidence if neither
of you knows the solution so that you
raise your hand and say i don't have a
clue what's going on here
so the idea is that once a week we do a
software lab individually once a week we
do a design lab a little more open-ended
with partners
there's a little bit of written homework
for total it's not much compared to
other subjects it's mostly practice
there's a nano quiz
just to help you keep pace to make sure
that you don't get too far behind
the first 15 minutes of every design lab
starts with a nano quiz the nano quizars
are intended to be simple
if you've caught up if you're up to date
so the idea is that you go to design lab
the first thing you do is a little 15
minute nano quiz the nano quiz uses a
tutor much like the homework tutor much
like the python tutor
and it's intended to be simple
but it does mean
please get to the design lab on time
the nano quizzes are administered by the
software
it starts when the hour when the design
lab starts it times out 15 minutes later
so if you come 10 minutes late you'll
have five minutes to do something that
we plan to give you 15 minutes for
we will also have exams and interviews
the interviews are
intended to be
a one-on-one conversation about how the
labs went
and we will have two midterms and a
final
so that's kind of the logistics the idea
behind the logistics is practice theory
practice
come to the labs try things out make
sure you understand develop a little
code type it in see if it works
if it works you're on top of things
you're ready to get the next batch of
information from the lecture in readings
okay let's go on and let's talk about
the technical material
in the first module of the course in the
software module
we kicked the course off talking about
software engineering
for two reasons we'd like you to know
about software engineering it's an
incredibly important part of our
department
it's an incredibly important part of the
engineering of absolutely any system any
modern system
but we'd also like you to know about it
because it provides a very convenient
way to think about it's a convenient
language
to think about
the design issues
the engineering issues in all the other
parts of the class so it's a very good
place to start
so to what
what i will do today is talk about some
of the very simplest ideas
about abstraction and modularity in what
i think of as the lowest level of
granularity
how do you think about abstraction and
modularity at the micro scale
at the individual lines of code scale
as i said earlier we will as we progress
look at modularity and abstraction at
the higher scale
but we have to start somewhere and we're
going to start by thinking about how do
you think about abstraction and
modularity at the micro scale
special note about programming
so
what we are trying to do
is in the first two weeks ramp everybody
up
to some level of software security where
you feel comfortable
so the
first two weeks of this course is
intended to make you comfortable with
programming we don't assume you've done
extensive programming before
we want you to become comfortable that
you're not behind
and that's the focus of the first two
weeks exam
exercises
if you have little or no previous
background if you are uncomfortable
please do the python tutor exercises
if you have not
if you
do not have a lot of experience
programming if you're uncomfortable with
with the expectation that you can do
programming do that first
that takes priority over all the other
assignments during the first two weeks
in particular if you're uncomfortable
we will run a special python help
session on sunday
and if you attend that
you can get a free extension
the idea is
completing the tutor exercises is
intended to make you feel comfortable
that you have the software background to
finish the rest of the course
do that first
we will forgive falling behind in other
things
so that you feel comfortable with
programming
if at the end of two weeks you still
feel uncomfortable
we have a deal with 600
the python programming class
that they will allow you to switch your
registration from 601 to 600
but that expires
valentine's day
so you have to make up your mind before
valentine's day if you'd like to use
that option
so the idea is we'd like you to be
comfortable with programming if you
haven't programmed before do the python
tutor exercises go to software lab
go to design lab but work on the tutor
exercises
the staff will help you with them
you can go to office hours there's
office hours listed in on the home page
you should try to become comfortable and
you should try to set as your goal i'm
going to be comfortable before
valentine's day
and if you're not talk to a staff a
staff member about that
okay
so what do i want you to know about
programming
well we're going to use python
we selected python
because it's very simple
and because
it lets us illustrate some very
important ideas in software engineering
in a very simple context
that's the reason
one of the reasons that it's simple
is that it's an interpreter
after some initialization
the behavior of python is to fall into
an interpreter loop
the interpreter loop is
ask the user
what he would like me to do
read what the user types
figure out what they're talking about
and print the result repeat
very simple what that means is
that you can learn by doing
that's one of the points of today's
software lab
you can simply walk up to a computer
type the word python
what you type is in red
type the word python
it will prompt you
so this chevron
that says i'd like you to tell me
something to do i have nothing to do
if you type
python tries to interpret that in this
particular case
python says oh i see
that's a primitive data item that's an
integer
this person wants me to understand an
integer and so it will echo 2.
indicating that it thinks you've you
wanted to understand a simple integer
similarly if you type 5.7 it says oh i
got that that's a float
the person wants me to remember a
floating point number
and it will similarly echo the float
now of course the floats don't have a
um
so there's no exact representation for
floats right there's too many of them
right there's a lot of them
there's even more floats than there are
ins right
so it has an approximation
so it will print its approximation to
the float that you that it thinks you
are interested in
if you type a string hello
it'll say oh primitive data structure
string
and it'll print out that string
so the idea is one of the features of
python that makes it easy to learn
is the fact that it's interpreter-based
you can play around you can learn by
doing
now of course if the only thing it did
was simple data structures it would not
be very useful
so the next more element the next more
complex thing that it can do is think
about combinations
if you type two plus three it says oh i
got it this person is interested in a
combination i should combine by the plus
operator two inch two and three
oh and if i do that if i combine by the
plus operator two and three i'll get
five so it prints five
so that's the way you know that it
interprets two plus three as five
similarly here except i've mixed types
5.7 plus three it says oh this user
wants me to pl apply the plus operator
on a float and in the end
okay well i'll upgrade the into a float
i'll do the
float version and i'll get
this which is its representation of 8.7
so the idea is that it will first try to
interpret what you're saying as a simple
data type
if that works it prints the result to
tell you what it thinks is going on it
then will try to interpret it as an
expression
and sometimes the expressions won't make
sense
in particular if you try to add an into
a string it's going to say huh and over
the course of the first two weeks we
hope that you get familiar with
interpreting this kind of mess
that's python's attempt to tell you what
it was trying to do on your behalf
and can't figure out what you're talking
about
okay so that was simple
but it already illustrates something
that's very important
and that's the idea of a composition
so
the way python works the fact that when
you added three to two
it came out five
what we were doing was composing
complicated well potentially complicated
that was pretty simple
potentially complicated expressions
and reducing them to a single data
structure
and so that means that in some sense
this operation three times eight
can be thought of
as exactly the same as if the user had
typed in 24
whenever you can substitute
for a complex expression
a simpler thing we say that the the
system is compositional
that's a very powerful idea even though
it's simple it's a very powerful idea
and it's an idea that you all know
you've seen it before in algebra in
arithmetic
so in arithmetic expressions you can
think about how
the sum of two integers is an int
that's a closure that's a kind of a
combination
that makes the system compositional and
that provides a layer of
hierarchical thinking so that in your
head
even though it says three times eight
you don't need to remember that anymore
you can say oh for for any purposes that
follow i might just as well think of 3
times 8 as being a single integer 24.
it's part of
many other kinds of systems
for example natural language
the simplest example in natural language
is that you can think about apples are
good as snacks apples is a noun
it's a plural noun
or you could substitute apples and
oranges
and it makes complete sense within that
same structure so apples and oranges are
good as
snacks the the combination of apples and
oranges
works
um
in every way from the point of view of
the grammar
in the same way that a simple noun
apples
worked what we would like to do is use
that idea
as the starting point
for a more general compositional system
and a good way to think about that
is by way of names
what if we had some sequence of
operations that we think is particularly
important
so that we would like to somehow
canonize that so that subsequently we
can use that sequence of operations
easily
python provides a very simple way to do
it
every programming language does it's not
unique to python
but the idea is so here's an example two
times two
i'm squaring two and get four three
times three i'm squaring three and i'm
getting nine
eight plus four times eight plus four
i'm squaring eight plus four eight plus
four well i can think of that as twelve
i'm squaring 12 i'm getting 144.
the thing i'm trying to illustrate there
is the notion of squaring
squaring is a sequence of operations
that i would like to be able to canonize
as a single entity so that in subsequent
programs i can think of the squaring
operation as a single operation
just like i think of times
the way we say that in python is define
square of x to be
return x squared
then
having made that definition i can say
square of 6 and the answer is
36. okay this is a very small step but
it illustrates a very important point
the idea being that
python provides a compositional
facility
and it's hierarchical
having defined square i can use square
just as though it were a primitive
operator
and i can use square to define higher
level
operations
so for example what if i were interested
in doing lots of sums of squares
say i'm pythagoras right
so
i might want to add the square of 2 and
the square of 4 to get 20
or the square of 3 with the square of 4
to get 25
using that simple idea of composition
we can write a new program sum of
squares
sum of squares takes two arguments x and
y
and it returns the square of x and the
square of y
sum of squares doesn't care
about how you compute the square
it trusts that square knows how to do
that
so the work is smaller
the idea is that square
takes care of squaring single numbers
sum of squares doesn't have to know how
to square numbers it just needs to know
how to add
make a sum of squares
so what we've done is we've broken a
task which was not very complicated but
the whole idea
is hierarchical
we've taken a problem and broken it into
two pieces we factored the problem into
how do you do a square and how to use
sum squares
and the idea then is that this
hierarchical structure is a way of
building complex systems
out of simpler parts
so that's the idea of how you would
build
programs
that are compositional
python also provides a utility for
making lists for making data structures
that are compositional
the most primitive is a list
so in python you can specify a list
here's a list of integers
so the list says beginning list end of
list elements of list so there's five
elements in the list
the integers one two three four five
python doesn't care
what the elements of a list are
we'll see in a minute that that's really
important
but for the time being the simplest
thing that you can imagine is a
heterogeneous list
it's not critical that the list contain
just integers
here's a list that contains an int a
string an int and a string
python doesn't care
it's a list that has four elements the
first elements in inch the second
elements a string etc
here's an even more complex example
here's a list of lists
how many elements are in that list
three
how many elements are in that list
so the idea is that you can build more
complex
data structures out of simple ones
that's the idea of compositional
factoring
applied to data
just like it was important when we were
thinking about
procedures to associate names with
procedures
that's what def did
we can also think about associating
names with data structures
and that's what we use something that
python calls a variable
form
so i can say b is three
and that associates the data item three
with the label
b i can say x is 5 times 2.2
python will figure out what i mean by
the expression on the right
it'll figure out that i'm composing by
using the star operator which is
multiply an integer and a float which
will give me a float
the answer to that's going to be a
floating point number
and it will assign a label x to that
floating point number
you can have a more complicated
uh list a data structure
and associate the name y with it then
having associated the name y you get
many of the same benefits
of associating a name with the data
structure that we got
previously in associating a name with an
operation
so we can say
y of zero and what that means is
what's the zeroth element
of the data structure y
so the zeroth element of the data
structure y is a list one two three
python has some funky notations
the minus one element is the last one
so the minus one element of y is seven
eight nine
and it's completely hierarchical
if i ask for the minus one element of y
i get seven eight nine but then if i ask
for the first element of that result
i get eight
okay everything everything is clear
okay
just make sure everything's clear i want
to ask you a question
but to kick off the idea of working
together i'd like you to think about
this question with your neighbor
so before
thinking about this question everybody
stand up
introduce yourselves to your neighbor
okay
okay
so now
so now i'd like to i'd like you to each
discuss with your neighbor
the list that is best represented by
which of the following figures one two
three four or five none of the above
and in 30 seconds i'm going to ask
everybody to raise a hand with the
number of fingers indicating the right
answer
you're allowed to talk
that's the whole point of having a
partner yeah
so
okay
i'd like everybody now to raise their
hand
put up the number of fingers that show
the answer and i want to tally
fantastic everybody gets it okay so
what's
so which one do you like
three
why do you like three somebody explain
this to me
it just looks good
it's pattern recognition
what's good about three
compositional what is the compositional
element in the pictures
what represents what
okay a represents a
that's pretty easy right
so that takes care of the bulk of the
figures what's the blue lines represent
someone else's
the vertex the vertices are lists
so in three
at the highest level we have a list
that's composed of how many elements
two
the first element of that list is
and the second element of that list is
another list that's the hierarchical
part
right
that second list has how many elements
finally reverse you got it
what is the list represented by number
two
a single list with five elements
square bracket a comma b comma c comma d
comma e
square bracket
right what is the list represented by
that one
it's not a list
right
what is it who knows
so we could make that a variable
if we said a is a variable that
comprises b and c
then we have the problem of how we're
going to associate variables and
elements
into this list right
so the weird thing about this one and
let's see that one's weird this one's
also kind of weird this one's weird
because we're giving names
to lists
in a fashion that's not showed up here
right
that's not to say you couldn't invent a
meeting it's just that it doesn't map
very well to that representation
similarly over here we seem to be giving
the the name b to the element a
and then the name c to the element b
what on earth it's not clear what we're
doing there either
okay so the point is to get you thinking
about the abstract representation of
lists and how that maps into a complex
data structure that was the whole point
okay so we've talked about then
four things so far
how do you think about operations
in a hierarchical fashion
and the idea was composition
we think about composing simple
operations to make bigger compound
operations
that's a way of saying
there's this set of operations that i
want to call foo
so every time i do this complicated
thing that has three pages of code
that's one food
and that's a way that we can then
combine foods
in some other horribly complicated way
to make big foods
right so the idea is composition that's
the first idea the second is is
associating a name
with that composition that's what def
does define name
name of a subroutine
so we thought about composing operations
associating names with them we composed
data in terms of lists and we associated
names with those lists in terms of
variables the next thing we want to
think about is a higher order construct
where we would like to conglomerate into
one data structure
both data and procedures
python has a concept called a class that
lets us do that
in python you make a new class by saying
to the python prompt i want a new class
called student
and then under student
there is this thing
which we will call an attribute
an attribute of to a class is simply a
data item associated with the class
and a method
a method is just a procedure
that is associated with a class so
there's this the single item class
called student
that has one piece of data
its attribute school
and one
procedure
which is the method calculate final
grade so then this is the kind of data
structure you might imagine that a
registrar would have
it's a way to associate
so the idea here is that everybody here
is a student
they all have a school
and they all have a way of calculating
their final grade
that's a very narrow view that maybe a
registrar would have
so
classes having defined them
we can then use the class to define an
instance
so an instance
is a data structure
that
inherits
all of the structure from the class
but also provides a mechanism for having
specific data
associated with the instance
so
in python i say mary is a student
by mentioning the name of the class and
putting parenthesis on it i say give me
an instance of the student
so now mary is a name
associated with an instance
of the class student
john is similarly an instance
of the class student
so both mary and john
have schools in fact they're both the
same
the school of mary and the school of
john are both mit
but
i can you i can extend
the instance of mary
to include a new attribute
the section number
so that mary's section number is three
and john's section number is four so
this provides a way it's a higher order
concept right
we thought of a way to aggregate
operations into complicated operations
data into complicated data
classes aggregate data and
operations
classes allow us to create a structure
and then generate instances and then the
instances
have access to those
features
that were defined in the class but also
have the ability to define their own
unique
attributes and methods
you can also use a class to define a
subclass
so here i'm defining the subclass
student 601
all students 601s are members of the
class student
the reverse is not true
so all students in all student 601
entities inherit everything that a
student has
but all 601 students share
some other things
besides having a school which all
students have 601 students also have a
lecture day a lecture time and a method
for calculating tutor scores
not all students have a way have a
method for calculating tutor scores but
six members of the class student 601 do
so this again represents a way of
organizing data
and operations
in a way that makes it easier to compose
higher
bigger more complex structures
the final thing that i want to talk
about today
is the specific gory details
for how python manages the association
between names
and entities
we've already seen two of those
naming operations is via def
and it gives rise to the name of a
procedure
variables are ways of naming data
structures
now we've seen a way of naming
uh
classes
and in fact it's helpful if you unders
so python
associates names and entities in a very
simple straightforward fashion and if
you know the ground rules it makes it
very easy to deal with and if you don't
know the ground rules it makes it very
hard to deal with so what's the ground
rules here's the gory details
so python associates names with value
values
in what python calls a binding
environment
an environment is just a list
that associates a name and an entity
so if you were to type b equals three
what python is actually doing
is it's building this environment
when you type b equals three it adds to
the environment
and a name b
and associates that
name
with the integer 3.
when you type x equals 2.2
it adds a
name x
and associates it with the float 2.2
when you say foo is minus 506 times 2
it makes the name foo and associates it
with an int minus 1012
then
if you ask python about b
the rule is look it up in the
environment
and type the thing that b refers to
so when you type b what python really
does is it goes to the environment it
says do i have some entity called b well
yes i do
it happens to be an n3 so it prints
three
if you ask what is a
python says okay in my environment do i
have some um
name
a
it doesn't find it so it prints out this
cryptic message
that basically says sorry guys i can't
find something called a
in the current environment
that's the key to the way python does
all name bindings
so
in general there's a global environment
you start typing to python
it just starts adding and modifying
the bindings in the binding environment
so if you type a equals three and then
type a it'll find three
if you then type b equals a plus two
it evaluates the right hand side
relative to the current environment
so it first looks here and it says do i
have something called a
ah yes i it's an integer 3.
substitute that
do i know what 2 is oh yeah that's just
an n do i know what plus is oh yeah
that's the thing that combines two ends
so it decides that a plus two
it evaluates a plus two in the current
environment it gets five
and it says oh i'm trying to do a new
equals a new association a new variable
make the
name b
point to
this evaluated in the current
environment so b gets associated with
the int
5.
then if i do this line it it evaluates b
plus one in the current environment
b is five in the current environment it
adds one it gets six
and then it says associate this thing
six
with b
so it overwrites the b which had been
bound to five
and its b is now bound to six
okay so the whole thing the way it
treats variables
the way it associates the way python
associates a name with a value in a
variable is evaluate the right hand side
according to the current environment
then change the current environment
to reflect the new binding
what it does in the case of sub routines
is very similar
when you say so here's an illustration
of the
the local environment
that
is generated by this piece of code
when i say a equals two it generates a
name in the local environment a
it evaluates the right hand side and
finds two
so it makes a binding in the local
environment where the name a is
associated with the integer 2.
then
i say define square of x to be return x
squared
that's more complicated
python says oh i'm defining a new
operation
it's a procedure
the procedure has a formal argument x
it has a body return x times x
i'm going to have to remember all of
that stuff
so i'm trying to define a new procedure
called square it's going to make a
binding for square
so in the future if somebody says the
word square it'll find out oh square i
remember that one square
it's a procedure
just like the binding for a variable
might be an int the binding for
a procedure
is the name of the procedure
then
in the procedure which is some other
data structure outside the environment
it's got to remember the formal
parameters in this case x
and the body
and for the purpose of resolving
what do the variables mean it needs to
remember
what was the binding environment in
which this subroutine was defined
so that's the that's this arrow
so
this this sequence says make a new
binding square points to a procedure the
procedure has the formal argument x
it has the body return x times x
and it has the binding it has it came
from the environment e1
the current environment
okay is everybody clear so the idea is
that the environment associates names
with things the thing could be a data
item or it could be a procedure
then when you call a procedure
it makes a new environment
so what happens then when i try to
evaluate a form square of a plus 2
what python does is it says okay
i need to figure out what square is
so it looks it up in the environment and
it finds out that square is a procedure
fine i know how to deal with procedures
so then it
figures out this procedure has a formal
argument x
oh okay if i'm going to run this
procedure i'm going to have to know what
x means
so python makes a new environment here
it's labeled e2
separate from the the global environment
e1
it makes a new environment
that will associate x with something
doesn't know what it is yet
it just knows that the square is a
procedure that takes a formal argument x
so python makes a new environment e2
with x pointing to something
then python evaluates the argument a
plus two in the environment e1
you called square of a plus two in the
environment e1 so it figures out what
did you mean by a plus
a plus three
well you were in the environment
e1 so it means whatever a plus three
would have meant
if he had just typed a plus three in
that environment so you evaluate a plus
3 in the environment e 1 and you get 5.
so then this new environment e 2
that is set up for this procedure square
associates 5 with x
now it's ready to run the body
so now it runs this procedure return x
times x
but now when it's trying to resolve its
variables
it looks it up in e2
so he says i want to do the
procedure the body x times x i need to
know what x is and i need to know it
twice
look up what x means
but i will look it up in my e2
environment that was built specifically
for this procedure
and fortunately there's an x there
so it finds out that x is five it
multiplies five times five it gets the
answer is 25 it returns 25
and then it destroys this environment e2
because it was only necessary for the
time when it was running the procedure
body
okay so a
slightly more difficult example
illustrates what happens whenever
everything is not defined in the current
local environment
what if i typed define biz of a
well
i create a new
name
in the in the local environment
that points to a procedure
the procedure has a formal parameter a
and a body that returns a plus b
the procedure also has was defined
within the environment e1 which i'll
keep track of
then if i say b equals sex that makes a
new binding in the global environment
b equals six
then if i try to run biz of two
look up biz oh that's a procedure formal
parameter a make an environment has an a
in it what should i put in a evaluate
the argument to okay a is two put two
here
now i'm ready to run the body
run the body in the environment e2
when i run return a plus b in e2
i have to first figure out a
well that's easy a is
two then i have to figure out b what's b
six how do you get six
so
this local environment that was created
for the formal parameter
has as its parent e1
because that's where the procedure was
defined
so it doesn't find b
in the in this local environment
so it goes to the parent do you have a b
and it could in principle propagate up a
chain of environments
so you could construct this
hierarchically so it will resolve
bindings
in the most recent environment that has
that binding
so the answer then is that
when you run biz of two this b
gets associated with that b
okay
so that's how how the
environments work for simple procedures
and simple data structures
it's very similar for the way it works
with classes
so imagine that i had this data
and i wanted to represent that in python
what i might do is look at the common
features the courses are all the same
the rooms are all the same the buildings
are all the same the ages are highly
variable
so i might want to create a class that
has the common data
so i might do this
class staff 601
the course is 601 the building's 34 the
room is this
the way python
implements
a class
is as an environment
executing this
set of statements
builds the class environment this is it
it's a list of bindings
here i'm binding the name course to the
string 601
etc if there were a method i would do
the same thing except it would look like
a procedure then
so
this
creates
the staff 601
environment
staff 601 because i executed this class
and statement this class statement that
creates a binding in the local
environment
staff 601
which points to
the new environment
so now in the future when python
encounters the name staff 601 it will
discover that that's an im that's a
that's an environment
python implements classes
as environments
so now
when i want to access
elements within a class
i use a special notation it's a dot
notation
python regards dots
as ways of navigating an environment
when python parses staff point room
it looks up staff 601 in the current
environment
if it finds an environment
it then says oh i know about this dot
room thing all i do is i look up the
room
name
in the environment
staff 601
and when it does that it gets the answer
501
and the same sort of hat thing happens
here it looks up staff 601 it finds an
environment
it looks up coolness it finds out there
is no such thing well no that's not true
so it creates coolness within 601
and assigns a variable
and assigns an integer 11 to it
so then
the way classes
the way python treats methods
is completely analogous
so um oh no excuse me instances so i'm
doing instances first
if i make pat be an instance of staff
601
pat is an instance of the class
staff 601
pat
is implemented
as an environment
so when i make pat
pat points to a new environment
here e3 the parent of e3 is the class
the pat belongs to which is here e2
and when i make the instance it's empty
but now if i
ask what is pat dot course well pat
points to this environment does this
environment have something called a
course no
does the parent yes
of course is bound to the string 601 so
pat dot chorus is 601
just the same as staff 601.course had
been 601
pat's a new instant pat is an instance
it's a new environment with the
class
environment as its parent
you can add
instances
you can add attributes to instances
and all that does is populate
the environment associated with the
instance
you can add methods
to classes
and that does the same thing
so here i've got the class staff 601
which has a method salutation
and
instance variables course building in
room
so when i build that structure staff 601
points to an environment
that contains salutation which is a
procedure
in addition to a bunch of instance
variables
so now all the rules that we've talked
about with regard to environments apply
now to this class
so in particular
i can say staff 601 salutation of pat
when python parses staff 601 it finds an
environment
it says dot salutation oh i know how to
do that within the when within the
environment staff 601
look for
a
binding for the name
salutation
do i find one well yeah there it is it
points to a procedure so staff dot
salutation is a procedure do just the
same things that we would have done with
a simple procedure the only difference
here is that the procedure came from a
class
in this particular case
the
the subroutine that i define
has a formal parameter self
so then that build that's going to have
to build when i try to evaluate it that
has to build
a local that has to build a binding
for self
which is set to pat
pat was an environment so self gets
pointed to pat
so now when i run staff.601 salutation
on pat
it behaves as though that generic method
was applied to the instance pat
we'll do that a lot it's a little bit of
redundancy we know that pat is a member
of staff 601
so we will define a special form or i
should say python defines a special form
that makes that easy to say
this is the way we will usually say the
instance pat should run
the
class method salutation
on itself
this is simply a simplified notation
that means precisely that
okay
so
what we covered today then was supposed
to be the most elementary ideas
in how you construct
modular programs
modularity at the small scale
how do you make operations that are
hierarchical data structures and classes
what we will do for the rest of the week
is practice those activities